comme obélix quand je suis plus depuis
petit je suis tombé dans la marmite
je dirais que mon premier ordinateur en
gt en fait déjà en fête à l'école
primaire ont commencé à apprendre les
premiers langages et depuis ça ne m'a
jamais en fait lâché et je continue
jusqu'à présent fait apprendre encore
apprendre en fait de nouveaux langages
de nouvelles technologies pour rester en
fait au fait de l'innovation en sortie
digitale et le tarn et passe-partout par
tout achat que par les outils par le
matérialisme entre eux que je disais le
monde est devenu mobile là il ya de gros
enjeux en fait si l'on utilisait le
parti intelligence artificielle et la
réalité augmentée et donc quel que soit
l'endroit où on se trouve
il faut prendre en fait se vivra j'en
fait du numérique et la martinique n'y
échapperez pas les volumes générés de
façon globale comme l'ensemble de la
planète
v en tous les usages que propose en fait
l'informatique de façon globale donc ça
va effectivement de tout ce qui n'était
ni chasse artificielle et au ski réalité
virtuelle et nous en sommes en fait
également consommateur et donc c'est une
véritable avancée au niveau des usa bat
d'offres et ambitieux en fait de
développement déjà sur notre zone et
locales en martinique il ya six ans fait
en guadeloupe une fois stratégie en fait
être de positionnement à fait à ce
niveau mais c'est vrai que depuis
l'année dernière je supportais 3 - fait
à miami pour développer pour avoir une
vraie implantation en fait sur la
floride et ça se traduit déjà par un
point de présence en fait physique au
niveau de miami et donc on a un
une vraie envie de commencer en fait par
la floride ou avoir un véritable
développement au niveau de toute la
caraïbe
c'est une nouvelle intervention
également la caraïbe également
l'amérique latine
donc je dirais que toutes les
entreprises se trouvent en fait au
niveau de ce hub et il nous semblait
pertinent au fait de commencer par la
floride pour pouvoir en fait ce faisant
se développe et se positionner en fait
sur la caraïbes et l'amérique latine
exactement martinique guadeloupe guyane
et réunion on a déjà en fait un certain
nombre de clients donc on continue en
fait à renforcer ce positionnement fête
locale avec eux comme l'on disait tout à
l'heure l'envi en fait de se développer
sur l'international en fait là que je
dirais que l'accompagnement digital se
fait en fait à tous les niveaux donc la
formation nous tient à coeur je suis moi
même personnellement en fait enseignants
sur le campus de schoelcher où
j'enseigne en informatique aux étudiants
de 3e année donc c'est des choses en
fait qui fait partie en fait de notre à
nadine et on veut en fait transmettre le
savoir et d'un accompagnement
je veux dire que la formation des jeunes
est obligatoire par rapport à ce jour
par rapport à leur avenir est ce qu'on
peut travailler en fait dans ce secteur
là alors je dirais que la chance qu'ils
ont c'est que oui on assiste en fait à
une véritable explosion en fait du nom
du digital
donc en fait je dirais que les
informaticiens afin de les étudiants qui
étudie l'informatique mais pas que
en fait on vont trouver en fait deux
des travaux ont fait dans la réunion par
rapport à ça